[Musique]
d'abord parce que j'ai été alerté par un
certain nombre d'habitants locataires du
parc social de la ville nous expliquant
qu' il venait de retrouver de recevoir
effectivement un rappel de provisions de
charges avec des augmentations très
lourde en cette fin d'année et que
d'abord il ne comprenait pas forcément
le pourquoi de cette hausse est ensuite
que nous alerter sur le fait qu'ils
auraient beaucoup de mal à régler ses
factures
[Musique]
vous avez des hausses assez différente
mais les ordres de grandeur sont entre
20 et 150 euros mensuels
ce que je demande aux bailleurs c'est
d'abord c'est de leur faire prendre
conscience qu'en cette période très
compliquée pour tout le monde que ce
soit les particuliers ou les
institutions tout le monde doit faire un
effort voilà il ne s'agit pas simplement
d'informer qu'il va y avoir des hausses
ou de d'avoir des mesures
d'accompagnement alors dans les mesures
d'accompagnement il ya le travail des
travailleurs sociaux par exemple un
aussi mais aussi le fait d'aménager les
calendriers de paiement d'avoir une
certaine bienveillance moi ce que je
demande c'est qu'il y ait des actions
immédiates et urgente selon et
trébuchantes
[Musique]